salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
le trésor des Templiers je suis sûr que
vous en avez tous entendu parler la
légende raconte qu'il serait composé de
pièces d'or de pierres précieuses et de
bijoux d'une valeur inestimable depuis
plus de 9 siècles personne n'a encore
réussi à mettre la main dessus alors
aujourd'hui moi aussi j'ai décidé de
partir à sa recherche et vous allez voir
les pistes ne manquent
[Musique]
pas certains parmi vous ont peut-être vu
le film Benjamin Gates et le trésor des
Templiers avec Nicolas Cage Benjamin le
héros part à sa recherche aux États-Unis
ça paraît presque trop Simp alors à
Hollywood on a vraiment peur de rien
parce que je préfère vous prévenir
malgré certaines légendes il n'y a
aucune chance pour que le trésor se
trouve de l'autre côté de l'Atlantique
si ce trésor existe bien c'est en France
qu'il se cache mais nous y reviendrons
tout à l'heure avant de vous révéler le
nom des lieux où il pourrait se trouver
il faut d'abord que je vous explique qui
étaient les Templiers et si vous avez
déjà joué au célèbrees jeux vidéo
Assassin's Creed vous voyez forcément de
quoi je pas ce sont les moines soldats
enemi juré de la confréie des assassins
les Templiers à l'époque ce sont nos
fameux moines soldats mais aussi
beaucoup de gens combattants ou non qui
ne sont pas des chevaliers chevaliers au
combat porte la fameuse tenue blanche à
Croix Rouge mais cette dernière n'est
absolument pas systématique souvent les
Templiers Arbor également leur randard
noir et blanc qu'on appelle le bosséan
et pour différencier les chevaliers des
simples soldats c'est facile les
chevaliers sont en blanc les simples
soldats en noir du côté de l'équipement
militaire Mo je vous ai apporté quelques
objets on a d'abord l'épée à une main
comme celle-ci puisque le mode à demain
sera utilisé uniquement après la fin des
Templiers un grand bouclier et une lance
complète les armes de base et pour
l'armure ils utilisent la côte de Maï
pour le casque au début on a ce genre-là
qui protège la tête et le nez et sur la
fin des homes fermés mais qui représente
finalement une toute petite période de
l'histoire des Templiers là encore il
faut oublier les clichés d'Internet mais
le templier qui était-il vraiment leur
histoire débute au Moyen-Orient au
lendemain de la Première Croisade à la
toute fin du 11e siècle à cette époque
les chevaliers croisés ont pris
possession de Jérusalem et ils n'ont
qu'une obsession protéger la ville
sainte ainsi que l'ensemble des
territoires conquis par les chrétiens au
Moyen-Orient des terres des villes et
d'impressionnantes fortifications ils se
sont aussi donnés pour mission d'assurer
la protection des pèlerins qui se
rendent à Jérusalem pour se recueillir
parce qu'à l'époque les routes sont
pleines de dangers pour mener à bien
cette mission quelques chevaliers
croisés décident de fonder un ordre
l'Ordre du Temple il se compose de
chevaliers qui ont pour particularité
d'être aussi des moines mais aussi de
nombreux civils et des combattants non
religieux l'ordre est officiellement
reconnu au concile de tro en 1129 le
premier grand maître est HUG Depin un
chevalier du Nord de la France au cours
du 12e siècle les Templiers imposent
leur présence partout dans les
territoires contrôlés par les chrétiens
au Moyen-Orient on l'a dit mais aussi en
Europe pour l'essentiel en France en
Angleterre et un peu en Espagne ces Moes
soldats deviennent très vite une force
politique avec laquelle il faut compter
et ils n'hésite pas à dépasser le cadre
originel de leur mission en participant
à de nombreuses batailles c'est par
exemple le cas de celle de atin en 1187
elle oppose les forces du royaume de
Jérusalem aux troupes de Saladin c'est
une cuisante défaite pour l'armée
occidentale l'Ordre du Temple est
également devenu extrêmement riche au
fil du temps les templions ont réussi à
mettre en place un gigantesque réseau
commercial et territorial ils
entretiennent des forteresses des
châteaux et des commanderies qui leur
rapportent beaucoup d'argent les
commanderies templières sont des
domaines tenant à la fois du monastère
et de la ferme elles sont réservées au
personnel militaire aux religieux et aux
paysans qui cultivent les terres du
temps rien qu'en France on en compte
plusieurs centaines elle leur
rapporterait énormément sous forme d'ord
de bijou et de pierrerie bien entendu et
selon la légende ce fabuleux magot
serait enfermé dans de très nombreux
coffres en bois et tout cela bien
entendu placé sous bonne garde dans une
pièce secrète dont seul le Grand Maître
de l'Ordre des Templiers aurait la clé
bien sûr l'argent du temple ne sert pas
à enrichir personnellement nos Templiers
qui ont fait vœux de pauvreté ils
permettent d'entretenir leur possession
les gens qui travaillent pour eux les
actions en TER saintte mais aussi à
accorder des prês l'ordre fonctionne
comme une gigantesque banque qui a la
réputation de faire d'énormes profits et
on a à peine TR siècles les Templiers
s'imposent comme une des premières
puissances militaires et financières
d'Occident et ça ça ne plaît pas à tout
le monde il y a un homme en particulier
très puissant qui veut leur poau c'est
le roi de France Philippe Lebel en ce
tout début de 14e siècle c'est déjà un
grand monarque en quelques années il a
su moderniser la France et réformer son
administration il a aussi pris ses
distances avec l'église qu'il juge trop
puissante les Templiers qui sont
soutenus par le pape représente donc une
menace à ses yeux enfin ce qu'il convoit
par-dessus tout bien entendu c'est leur
immense fortune pour mettre la main
dessus il piège les Templiers Philippe
Lebel accuse ces derniers de rides obsen
et d'outrage envers le Christ et rien
que ça à l'époque ces accusations qui
sont absolument terrible et le 13
octobre 1307 il les fait arrêter la
plupart des Templiers sont emprisonnés
quelques-uns sont torturés pour avouer
leur crime supposé évidemment sous la
torture on avoue un peu n'importe quoi
l'ordre lui est tout simplement supprimé
ce qui permet à Philippe Lebel de
s'emparer des très nombreuses possession
des Templiers les commanderies et les
terres de quoi renflouer confortablement
les caisses de l'État toutefois je vous
le rappelle la légende raconte qu'une
grande partie du trésor des Templiers se
trouverait dans des coffres beaucoup de
coffres or bah ceux-ci sont introuvable
les moines chevaliers croupissent en
prison pendant plusieurs années et
finalement le 18 mars 1314 7 ans après
son arrestation leur chef Jacques de
mollet est conduit au bûcher et ce
jour-là un événement incroyable se
serait produit au moment où les flammes
ont commencé à le dévorer Jacques de
molet aurait lancé une terrible
malédiction à l'encontre de ceux qui ont
s l'honneur des Templiers le roi France
bien entendu mais aussi le pape Clément
5 qui n'a pas levé le petit doigt pour
les défendre soyez tous maudits jusqu'à
la 13e génération de
vos et bien aussi incroyable qu'il
puisse paraître son vœu est rapidement
exaucé parce que le Pape Clément 5 il
meurt un mois plus tard en avril 1314 en
novembre c'est au tour de Philippe
Lebelle il passe l'arme à gauche à la
suite d'une étrange chute de cheval il a
à peine 46 ans dans la foulée son fils
Louis 10 meurt prématurément d'un coup
de froid à seul ement 26 ans puis c'est
le petit Jean dit Jean Le Postume censé
prendre sa suite qui disparaît alors
qu'il n'a que 5 jours son successeur
disparaît avant ses 30 ans le suivant à
33 bref le malheur frappe la famille
royale et lorsque Charles I passe l'arme
à gauche il n'y a plus d'héritier mal
direct pour occuper le trône de France
mais revenons à ce qui nous intéresse le
fameux trésor contenu dans des coffres
on raconte que juste avant leur
arrestation les Templiers ont pris des
dispositions pour qu'il échappe au roi
plusieurs chariots remplis d'or et de
bijoux auraient quitté la France pour
leséc un pays moins hostile un document
retrouvé dans les archives du Vatican
signale par exemple qu'un templier nommé
Gérard Villier se serait enfui avec 50
chevaux et aurait pris la mer sur 18
galères quand même d'autres sources
mentionnent que les coffres auraient été
planqués par les familles de certains
membres de l'ordre mais où alors
probablement dans les sous-sols d'un
château d'une abbaye voire dans un
cimetière les histoires mystérieuses ne
manquent pas mais cette histoire de
cimetière est revenue en 1885 grâce à
Béranger sonnière un prêtre qui officie
à Ren le château dans le longdoc il
aurait selon certains témoins découvert
le trésor des Templiers dans le
cimetière du village de l'or de l'or de
l'or du jour au lendemain le curé se met
à dépenser sans compter il restaure le
sanctuaire à grand frais achète
plusieurs terrains et choque sa
hiérarchie par ses extravagances en
France l'affaire fait la Une des
journaux il faut attendre 1990 pour
qu'un historien français Jean-Jacques
Bedu prouve bah qu'en réalité l'abbé
avait détourné de l'argent des messes
cette piste AB donc à une impasse en
1964 le ministre de la Culture André mer
ordonne également des fouilles
archéologiques au château de Gizor en
Normandie la raison et bien un ancien
guide touristique prétend y avoir
découvert 19 sarcophages de pierre qui
pourrait abriter le fameux trésor
l'hypothèse est crédible car plusieurs
membres du Temple y ont été emprisonnés
au 14e siècle Jacques demolet lui-même
le dernier grand maître de l'ordre en
faisait d'ailleurs partie mais après 3
mois d'effort c'est la déception on ne
trouve à absolument rien tout au long du
20e siècle la question du Trésor refait
régulièrement sur faceace livres film
séries tout ça il fait régulièrement
référence mais la légende perdure et en
98 c'est le coup de théâtre on croit
enfin avoir découvert le trésor dans un
domaine situé à peint un village de
l'Aube un certain Bernard de la Cour a
déterré un lot de 708 pièces d'argent
datant de la fin du 11e siècle et il en
est certain il a découvert le trésor des
Templiers pour valider son hypothèse il
s'appuie sur un argument imp
le tout premier propriétaire de ce
domaine n'est autre CUC de pain vous
vous souvenez c'est le tout premier
Grand Maître de l'Ordre des Templiers
mais cette fois encore c'est une fausse
piste ces pièces d'or sont bien
antérieur à l'arrestation des Templiers
pas de chance bon alors ce trésor vous
en pensez quoi vous il existe ou pas
finalement bon si vous voulez mon avis
toutes ces histoires de malédiction et
de trésor et bah c'est du vent la
fameuse malédiction de Jack de molet sur
le boucher vous serez maudit machin
machin en réalité elle a été inventée de
toutes pièces en 1300 30 16 ans après
son exécution elle ne deviendra célèbre
que de siècles plus tard à travers
plusieurs auteurs parce que les gens
aimaient déjà les histoires un peu
mystérieuse à cette époque hein quant à
la mort soudaine de Philippe Le belle un
simple accident de cheval qui lui aurait
provoqué un choc à la tête et une
hémorragie cérébrale celle du pape
Clément 5 n'a absolument rien de suspect
non plus il avait 50 ans et mourir à 50
ans à l'époque bah ça a rien d'étonnant
quant au successeur de Philippe Lebel
disparu prématurément ça n'a rien de
surprenant non plus au Moyen-âge les
gens pouvaient parfois mourir assez
jeunes et ben je vais peut-être vous
décevoir mais il y a aussi de fortes
chances pour que ces fameux coffres
remplis à rabord d'or et ben ils aient
jamais existé c'est probablement une
légende qui a traversé le temps comme je
vous l'ai déjà un peu dit la richesse
des Templiers elle résidait
principalement dans leur possession les
commanderies les forteresses les
comptoirs commerciaux et tout çaah en
fait c'est déjà Philippe Lebel qui s'en
était emparé une chose est sûre il reste
beaucoup à découvrir sur les moines
soldats les plus célèbre de tous les
temps et les découvertes archéologiques
à ce sujet seront des trésors pour la
connaissance mais voilà cette légende du
Trésor des Templiers c'est déjà une
belle histoire et moi j'adore les belles
histoires voilà les épicurieuses et les
épicurieux la chasse au trésor est fini
pour aujourd'hui et moi j'ai rien trouvé
et je suis pas plus riche qu'avant enfin
j'espère que cette histoire vous a plu
et surtout indiquz en commentaire les
sujets histoires que vous aimeriez que
l'on traite sur ce à très
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bientôt